I've been studying gelada monkeys on and
off for eight years now and I've seen
some incredible things whether it's the
live birth of a gelada infants from just
a few meters away to some intense fights
where I'm just kind of stuck in the
middle and geladas are ignoring me and
proceeding to tear the faces off each
other geladas just have very kind of
moments that as a researcher you don't
necessarily focus on but as a human
being that you can appreciate just being
frozen solid next to geladas on a really
windy day where you share a hailstorm
together sitting under a Ledge waiting
for the conditions to change you get to
understand the individual personalities
of them and that is something that I
didn't necessarily appreciate before I
started working here was how varied
individual animals of the same species
can be why do I do this um I it's hard
to talk in cliches you know and someone
asked that you know you're just
constantly having natural beauty thrown
into your face when you're sitting up
here like every sunset every sunrise is
spread taking your looking out over the
Rift Valley and if you have a bad day
all you have to do is look to the east
and realize oh wait you know I'm
standing a few thousand meters above
this huge pastoral expanse with cliffs
right next to me near a herd of you know
hundreds of monkeys life isn't so bad in
fact it's really interesting
[Music]
[Music]